In this exercise, I asked you to first download
both Week 1 sales and the customer rewards Excel documents,
leave them in the downloads folder and import each into power BI's Power Query.
Let me show you first how I did this myself.
First, I opened up Power BI and I used the initial screen to get data.
If you close out of your screen,
when you first open up Power BI,
you can always bring it back by hitting this button here, for "Get data".
We now navigate to the Excel option on the get data list and hit "Connect".
Now I'm going to move to my downloads folder.
I'll select Customer Rewards,
then I select the Table,
and I'll select Transform.
Here on the Power Query Editor,
I'm going to take the same steps,
but I'm going to use this button on the Home ribbon called New Source,
select Excel as well,
and I'll select Week 1 Sales from here,
choosing the relevant section,
which for this is just one for Week 1 sales.
Here you can see the second query readily available.
Next, I asked you to create a dedicated folder and move
the two files from the downloads folder for safekeeping,
which when I make this change,
will of course trigger an alert from Power BI.
Now that I've moved them both,
when I select Refresh, we get an error.
I rather cruelly set you up to run into an error at the end of this exercise,
one of the first things that I've noticed tends to really trip up new users in Power BI,
is when the data source changes,
but you're not sure how to fix it.
This is one of those micro skills that I think
sometimes gets overlooked when you're learning Power BI.
I wanted to give you a little hands-on experience on how it can
easily happen and how you can easily fix it.
Step 1, with the error message,
is not to panic.
There are a few different ways we can tackle this,
but first is to read the details.
We can see here that the datasource error listed is they can't find the file.
We have several different ways we can update this.
The most obvious is the go-to error,
which in this case wasn't super helpful.
We can see here that this is where it's
looking for the file that we're going to use for this query.
It's still not quite right.
To fix this, we can go to the source which is right here,
and we can browse.
Instead of going to the Downloads folder where it's looking for it and can't find it,
we're going to go to the folder where we saved it,
and the error disappears.
You can see the data is all right here as you'd expect.
If we run the same refresh on the first table,
we get the same problem.
I want to show you another way that you can fix this.
I like to use this option if you have multiple errors that have popped up.
This lists all of them together.
I'm just going to select the one that I want to fix,
choose Change Source, and then I'm going to perform the exact same steps.
Previously it was looking for it in downloads,
now I'm asking to look for it in my lesson 3 file.
Close and refresh.
Since source file locations and names are subject to change,
this is going to be important for you to know throughout your Power BI career.
Though, I expect it will come in handy through this course as well.
At the end of each exercise,
we have a solutions PBIX file for your reference,
and you can always use that to start your next exercise,
but each time you do so,
you need to update the source link to access your own desktop file.
Otherwise, it's going to keep trying to connect to my C drive.
If you forget how to make this fix later,
you can always come back to the solution in the course for reference.